nearly a hundred years ago
almost today most women in the united
states finally won the right to vote
now it would take decades more for women
of color to earn that right
and we've come a long way since but i
would argue
not nearly far enough i think what women
want today not just only in the united
states but around the globe
is to no longer be an afterthought
we don't want to continue to try to like
look at the next hundred years and be
granted grudgingly small legal rights
and accommodations
we simply want true and full equality
i think that women are tired of
retrofitting ourselves into
institutions and governments that were
built by men
for men and would we would rather
reshape the future
on our own terms i believe yeah
i believe what we need is a women's
political revolution for full
equality across race across class
across gender identity across sexual
orientation and yes
across political labels because i
believe what binds us together
as women is so much more profound than
what keeps us apart
and so i've given some thought about how
to build this women's political
revolution and that's what i want to
talk to you about
today so
um here's the good news is that
one thing that hasn't changed over the
last century is women's resilience
and our commitment to build a better
life not only for ourselves but for
generations to come
because i can't think of a single woman
who wants her daughter
to have fewer rights or opportunities
than she's had
so we know we all stand on the shoulders
of the women who came
before us and as for myself i come from
a long line of tough texas women
so my grandparents lived outside of waco
texas
in the country and when my grandmother
got pregnant
of course she was not going to go to the
hospital to deliver she was going to
have that baby at home
but when she went into labor she called
the neighbor woman over
to cook dinner for my grandfather
because
i mean it was unthinkable that he was
going to make supper for himself
but the um been there and but
the neighbor had no experience with
killing a chicken and that was what was
planned for dinner
that night and so as the story goes
my grandmother in the birthing bed in
labor
hoists herself up on one elbow and rings
that chicken's neck
right and that is how my mother came
into this world
right so
um but the amazing thing is
even though my mother's own grandmother
could not vote in texas because
under texas law quote idiots
imbeciles the insane and women
were prevented the franchise just two
generations later
my mother ann richards was elected the
first woman governor in her own right in
the state of texas
but you see when mom was when mom was
coming up in in texas there weren't a
lot of opportunities
for women and frankly she spent her
entire life trying to change that
um she used to like to say look as women
if you just give us a chance
we can perform after all ginger rogers
did
everything fred astaire did but she did
it backwards and in high heels
right and honestly that's kind of what
women have been doing for this last
century is that despite having very very
little
political power we have made enormous
progress
so today in the united states a hundred
years after getting the right to vote
women are almost half the workforce
and in forty percent of families with
children women are the major
breadwinners
economists even estimate that if every
single paid working woman
took just one day off of work it would
cost the united states
21 billion dollars in gross domestic
product
now in the because of largely because of
title ix which required educational
equity
women are actually now half the college
students in the united states we're half
the medical students
we're half the law students right
exactly
and i mean one of uh a fact i absolutely
love
one of the most recent classes of
graduating nassau astronauts was
what for the first time 50 women right
so the point is that women are really
changing industries they're changing
business from the inside out
but when it comes to government it's
another story
and i actually think a picture is worth
a thousand words
this is a photograph from 2017 at the
white house
when congressional leaders were called
over to put the final details into the
health care reform bill that was to go
to congress
now one of the results of this meeting
was that they got rid of maternity
benefits
which may not be that surprising since
no one at that table actually would need
maternity benefits
and unfortunately that's what we've
learned the hard way in the u.s for
women
if we're not at the table we're on the
menu
right and we're simply
we're simply not at enough uh tables
because even though women are the vast
majority of voters in the united states
we fall far behind the rest of the world
in political representation
recent research is that when they ranked
all the countries
the united states is 104th in women's
representation
in office 104th
right behind indonesia so
is it any big surprise then considering
who's making decisions
we're the only developed country with no
paid family leave
uh and despite all the research and
improvements we've made in medical care
and this is really horrifying to me the
united states now leads the developed
world
in maternal mortality rates
now when it comes to equal pay we're not
doing a whole lot better actually women
now on average in the united states
still only make
80 cents to the dollar that a man makes
though if you're an african-american
woman
it's 63 cents to the dollar and if
you're a latina
it's 54 cents to the dollar it's an
outrage
now uh women in the uk united kingdom
just came up with something i thought
was rather ingenious
in order to illustrate the impact of the
pay gap
so starting november 10th and going
through the end of the year
they simply put an out of office memo on
their email to indicate all the weeks
they were working
without pay right i think it's an idea
that actually could catch on but imagine
if women actually
had political power imagine if we were
at the table
making decisions imagine if we had our
own women's political party that instead
of putting our issues to the side as
distractions
made them the top priority
well we know research shows that when
women are office
they actually act differently than men
they collaborate more with their
colleagues they work across
party lines and women are much more
likely to support legislation that
improves access to health care
education civil rights and what we've
seen in our research in the united
states congress that women actually
they sponsor more legislation and they
co-sponsor more legislation so all the
evidence is
when women actually have the chance to
serve they make a huge difference
and they get the job done so how would
it look in the united states
if different people were making
decisions well i firmly believe
if half of congress could get pregnant
we would finally quit fighting about
birth control and planned parenthood
i think that would be over
i i also really believe that finally
businesses
might quit treating pregnancy as a
nuisance
and rather understand it is a primary
medical issue for millions of american
workers
and i think if more women were in office
our government would actually prioritize
keeping families together rather than
pulling them apart
but perhaps most importantly
i think all of these issues would no
longer be seen as women's issues
they would just be seen as basic issues
of fairness and equality that everybody
can get behind so
i think the question is what would it
take actually to build this women's
political revolution
well the good news is actually it's
already started
because women around the globe are
demanding workplaces
they're demanding uh they're demanding
educational institutions they're
demanding governments where sexism and
sexual harassment
and sexual assault are neither accepted
nor tolerated
women around the world as we know are
raising their hands and saying
me too and it's a movement is made so
much more powerful
by the fact that women are standing
together across industries from domestic
workers
to celebrities in hollywood
women are marching we're sitting in
we're speaking up women are challenging
the status quo
we're busting old taboos and yes we are
proudly
making trouble so women in saudi arabia
are driving for the very first time
right women in iraq
are standing in solidarity with
survivors of human trafficking
and women from el salvador to ireland
are fighting for reproductive rights
and women in myanmar are standing up for
human rights
in short i think the most profound
leadership in the world isn't coming
from halls of government
it's coming from women at the grassroots
all across the globe
so and here in the united states
women are on fire so a recent kaiser
poll reported that
since our last presidential election in
2016
one in five americans have either
marched or taken part in a protest and
the number one issue
has been women's rights women are
starting new organizations
they are volunteering on campaigns and
they're taking on
every issue from gun safety reform to
public education and women are running
for office in record numbers
and they are winning so
women women like lucy mcbath from
georgia
[Applause]
lucy lost her son to gun violence
and it was because of her experience
with the criminal justice system that
she realized
just how broken it is and she decided to
do something
about that so she ran for office and
this january
she's going to congress okay or um
angie craig from minnesota
so her congressman had made
such hateful comments about lgbtq people
that
she decided to challenge him and you
know what she did
and she won and when she goes to
congress in january she'll be the first
lesbian mother
serving in the house of representatives
okay
or our lauren underwood
from illinois she's a registered nurse
and she sees every day the impact of
lack of health care access
has on the community where she lives and
so
she decided to run she took on six men
in her primary she beat them all
she won the general election and when
she goes to congress in january
she's gonna be the first
african-american woman ever to serve her
district in washington d.c
right
so women are recognizing
this is our moment don't wait for
permission don't wait for your turn
um as the late great shirley chisholm
said shirley chisholm the first
african-american woman ever to go to
congress
and the first woman to run for president
in the democratic party
but shirley chisholm said if there's no
room for you at the table
just pull up a folding chair right and
that's what women are doing
all across all across the country uh
i believe women are now the most
important and powerful political force
in the world but how do we make sure
that this is not just a moment
what we need is actually a global
movement
for women's full equality that is
intersectional
and it's intergenerational where no one
gets left behind
and so i have a few ideas about how we
could do that
number one it's not enough to resist
it's not enough to say what we're
against it's time to be loud and proud
about what we are
for because being for full equality is a
mainstream
value and something that we can get
behind because actually
men support equal pay for women
millennials
they support gender equality and
businesses are increasingly adopting
family-friendly policies not just
because it's the right thing to do
because it's good for their workers
it's good for their business
number two we have to remember in the
words of
fannie lou hamer that nobody's free
till everybody's free so as i mentioned
earlier women of color in this country
didn't even get the right to vote until
much uh further along
than the rest of us but since they did
they are the most reliable voters
and women of color are the most reliable
voters for candidates who support
women's rights and we need to follow
their lead
all right because
their issues are our issues and as
white women we have to do more because
racism
and sexism and homophobia these are
issues
that affect all of us number three we
gotta vote in
every single election every election and
we gotta make it easier for folks to
vote
and we gotta make sure that every single
vote is counted okay
because the barriers that
that exist to voting in the united
states they fall disproportionately
on women women of color women with low
incomes
women who are working and trying to
raise a family
so we need to make it easier for
everyone to vote
and we can start by making election day
a federal holiday in the united states
of america
uh number four don't wait for
instructions
if you see a problem that needs fixing i
think you're the one to do it
okay so whether so right it's just
start a new organization run for office
or maybe it's as simple as standing up
on the job
in support of yourself or your
co-workers this is up
to all of us and number five invest in
women
all right invest in women as right
invest in women as candidates as change
makers as leaders
just as an example in this last election
cycle in the united states
women donated a hundred million dollars
more to candidates and campaigns
than they had just two years ago and a
record number of women
won so just think about that um
so look sometimes i think the
the challenges we face they seem
overwhelming and they seem like
there almost can never be solved but i
think it's those problems that seem the
most intractable or the ones that are
most important to work on
um and just because it hasn't been
figured out yet doesn't mean
you won't after all if women's work were
easy
someone else would have already been
doing it right
but women around the globe
they're on the move and they are taking
strength and inspiration
from each other they are doing things
they never could have imagined
so if we could just take the progress we
have made in joining the workforce
and joining business and joining the
educational system
and actually channel that into building
true political power
we will reshape this century because one
of us can be ignored
two of us can be dismissed but together
we're a movement
and we're unstoppable thank you
thank you you